dans les classes de l'école secondaire
le sommet de charlesbourg tous les
élèves ont une tablette électronique
ça fait cinq ans que léa trimballe la
sienne c'est un magnifique outil travail
ça nous permet de faire beaucoup de
projets beaucoup plus que coloré façon à
table ça nous motive vraiment beaucoup
plus ça permet que tu peux aller plus
loin que ce que les colts à monde il y a
6 ans cette école du réseau public a
pris le virage numérique
ici plus d'agenda papier plus de cahiers
d'exercices presque tout se fait sur la
tablette
il s'appelait à jacob un menton pas
aller chercher des capsules informatives
si on plus de complications difficulté
on peut aller chercher des cahiers en
ligne pour des exercices
j'essaie le plus possible d'être sous un
pâle soit écrit avec mon clavier ou avec
un stylo électronique dans cette école
de 1000 élèves les professeurs utilisent
leur tablette pour enseigner hier vous
avez fait un problème d'un outil qu'on
utilise qu'on utilise le plus con peu
puis ben joue être avec vous il ya des
matières que ça s'applique plus que la
hauteur et plusieurs enseignants tant au
québec qui passent leur recours à
remplir des tableaux
nous à notre école on est un peu
ailleurs le rapport au sol l'école
finance l'achat des appareils pour que
tous les enfants y aient accès les
parents trois ans pour les payer il doit
déboursent en moyenne 180 dollars par
année
on a aussi embauché une techno pédagogue
à temps plein dans l'école je m'occupe
de former les enseignants de former les
jeunes élèves l'eau à utiliser les
applications et technologies
résultat quand les écoles ont fermé à
cause de la pandémie tout le monde ici
est après à faire l'école à distance les
élèves n'avaient pas à se soucier de
s'approprier le goût du travail
donc en fait rapidement on a pu
s'organiser poursuivre au niveau de
l'enseignement de l'apprentissage mais
aussi d'avoir un contact je voudrais
rapide avec nous et les petits sûr qu'on
connaissait tout y est
pendant la quarantaine d'écoles distance
ça a été un bouche trou
moi j'ai trouvé ce faux-pas changement
entre acheter nous parce qu'on a arrêté
près nos deux jours après qu'ils ont
fermé les écoles là le 13 mars je pense
que le 15 mars on aurait pu embarquer
renseignements ligne directement pour
être prêts en cas de deuxième vague du
coronavirus le gouvernement du québec a
débloqué 150 millions de dollars pour
l'achat d'équipement informatique au
centre de service scolaire de montréal
on va acheter dix mille appareils en
beauce près de 7000 on va doter ces
chèques élèves de secondaire
d'un chromebook d'être sûr que chaque
étudiant puisse avoir un appareil donc
advenant le coq qui arrive c'est la
deuxième vague et on est obligé de
fermer les écoles mais on sait que nos
élèves 22 genre outillés pour cet expert
difficile d'imaginer que toutes les
écoles du québec seront prêtes dès
l'automne
ce sera tout un défi mais ce qui est
certain il faut pas se fier uniquement à
la présence d'appareils d'entre les
mains des élèves dans les écoles
ce sera réellement insuffisant il faut
vraiment miser à la fois sur la
formation des enseignants sur la
formation des jeunes aussi à l'école le
sommet il a fallu au moins un an pour
tout mettre en place et prendre le
virage vers le numérique
ici jean philippe robien radio canada
québec